معنا الان من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي سيد العقيد عندما نسمع حجاري
يتحدث عن ان تركيز الجهود على الوسط
والجنوب بمعنى انها قد اكملت مهمتها في
الشمال هل المؤشرات على الارض تدل على
ذلك نعم تحيه لك مشاهدي قناه الجزيره نعم
لا شك بان حده المواجهات المباشره
والاشتباكات ما بين فصائل المقاومه وما
بين القوات الصهيونيه في القطاع الشمالي
خفت في الفتره الماضيه بشكل كبير جدا
وهناك تصريحات تقول بانه الجيش الصهيوني
انتقل الى المرحله الثالثه والمرحله
الثالثه تعني بان هذه المنطقه تمت فيها
العمليات الكبيره وتم انسحاب
القطاعات المباشره في الاشتباك والان يتم
رصد هذه المنطقه عن طريق الطائرات المسيره
وعن طريق طريق نقاط رصد وعن طريق الاقمار
الصناعيه وما ذلك من امور اخرى يضاف الى
هذا بانه لازالت هناك بعض المناطق
المتواجده في الشمال تشكل بالنسبه لقطاعات
الجيش الصهيوني اهداف خصوصا وان هذه
المناطق تم الدخول اليها ولكن لم يتم
تفتيش هذه المناطق بدقه وبالتالي يمكن ان
تكون هناك عمليات محدوده الى مناطق معينه
في القطاع الشمالي ولكن لا نستطيع ان نقول
بانه تم انتهاء العمليات العسكريه بصوره
كامله ولكن يمكن ان تكون هناك عمليات اخرى
خلال الفتره القادمه اما في القطاع الاوسط
والقطاع الجنوبي فلا شك بانه بعد الهدنه
الاولى كانت التصريحات واضحه بانه ستكون
العمليه العسكريه الان باتجاه خان يونس ثم
بعد ذلك توسعت العمليه العسكريه لتكون على
جبهه واسعه تشمل القطاع الاوسط والقطاع
الجنوبي الان ما ما يجري ما يجري هو انه
حده الاشتباكات بصوره عامه حتى في القطاع
الاوسط والقطاع الجنوبي ايضا خفت بشكل
كبير وهذا يدعو الى كثير من التساؤلات
اولا يبدو بان الخسائر التي تكبدها الجيش
الصهيوني في الفتره الماضيه اجبرت هذا
الجيش على عدم التوغل كما كان معمول به في
القطاع الشمالي وهي يمكن احد الدروس التي
استوحاها الجيش من الخسائر الكبيره التي
تكبدها في القطاع الشمالي وبالتالي هو
يحاول الان التمركز في مناطق معينه ثم
القيام بعمليات العزل والتطويق بدون ان
تكون هناك خسائر كبيره ثم بعد ذلك يستخدم
عمليات التجريد الجوي لقصف الاهداف التي
يمكن ان تظهر من خلال المراقبه الجويه
وهذه المراقبه يمكن ان تتم من خلال
الطائرات المسيره وهو يمتلك اعداد كبيره
جدا خاصه السر 166 الذي فيه طائرات مسيره
من انواع من للاستطلاع والمراقبه وللقصر
وبالتالي هو يحاول السيطره على هذه
المناطق من خلال القصف الجوي ومن خلال
القصف المدفعي لذلك هو يحاول تجنب
الاشتباك المبا المباشر لتقليل الخسائر
ويحاول ايضا ان يسيطر على هذه المناطق من
خلال القضم المتدرج بدون ان تكون هناك
اشتباكات مباشره لتقليل حده الخسائر سواء
كانت في القاطع الاوسط او في القاطع
الجنوبيه اشكرك من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
واستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي